the surface water and ocean topography
satellite or SWAT will for the first
time perform detailed scans of all the
oceans lakes and large rivers on the
planet this data lake has understands
that the where is the water is where is
coming from and where it's going and
that's what really play a crucial role
of understanding the the climate changes
egyptian-born NASA engineer tahani armor
helped design the spacecraft we get a
look at the ocean features all the the
the front and the edgy and the small
details that occur that occur in the
surface of the ocean and trying to
understand and improve our models to be
able to know uh the ocean Rises the
effect of floods and those horrible
weather conditions that occurs
especially in the coastal line SWAT will
give us all of this information makes us
understand more detail of that
the satellite is a joint project by the
U.S Canada France and the UK the world's
oceans absorb more than 30 percent of
the heat trapping compound carbon
dioxide the SWAT satellite will provide
Vital Information on how this poorly
understood process actually works
information critical to understanding
global climate change
when the Earth's awesome gonna stop
absorbing heat and starting releasing
back in the atmosphere and how is that
gonna accelerate the global warming
right and we'll be able to help us
predict better model to predict what
could happen in the next 5 10 15 years
how does SWAT work it sends impulses
that bounce off surface water back to
its sensors over time its orbit will
cover the entire planet that digital
information can be converted into maps
and scientific data Amer grew up in a
time and place where girls were rarely
given the opportunity to pursue
Scientific careers
she credits her father's encouragement
for her career path and says her faith
also inspires her as you know I'm a
Muslim and there is a very clear Vivid
verse in the Quran is said about the
author you know uh thought of everything
every one of us here is is water I call
it water unite us right because without
water we will not have life at a time of
growing danger for earth and its
creatures SWAT will cast light on the
face of the deep
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los Angeles